maximum minimum problems which sounds
like a bad tongue twister which is why
we call the max min problems are a
really important category of problem in
mathematics because they're so practical
often we're trying to maximize something
get the most profit get the most people
on the buses get the the largest amount
of population in a particular area so
you you know make it bad and resources
and what-have-you maximize some
quantities or likewise minimize
something can you get the lowest cost
can you get the lowest greenhouse
emissions can you get the lowest fuel
consumption all those kinds of things
are an area where basically mathematics
reigned supreme so maximum problems are
a highly practical thing as an overall
umbrella we often call these maximum
problems in the real world we call these
optimization problems so the idea is
we're doing things right now in a way
that that's okay but I think we can make
it better I think we can get more
profits out of this even spending the
same amount of money or I think we can
get the same amount of profits but
spends less money we're trying to
optimize we're trying to improve the
situation the reason why we particularly
care about these within quadratics it's
because this so very easy to find there
so is it fun underneath this header you
draw for me just a quick set of axes and
it's very easy to illustrate the fact of
how easy it is to find a max or min
where what you're dealing with is the
quadratic function so here's a parabola
it doesn't have a minimum minimum saying
middle doesn't really make sense to you
because it goes down forever maybe this
is something like a profit and you're
trying to find the greatest profit well
it's just right there at the vertex
right and the vertex is a fairly easy
thing to find for quadratic in the same
way if I was looking for a minimum that
would be equally easy to find all I need
to do is find out where that middle spot
is and off I go there's the value that
will give me the minimum
there's the actual minimum itself okay
now we're solving quadratic equations
there are three techniques that we use
or three techniques that you can use
which are exactly alike to this maximum
problem right so the three techniques
are suggestions if you try to solve a
quadratic equation what could you do
what's the simplest method you could use
you can factor out right so when you
factorize a quadratic equation and you
say Oh uncle two factors make either the
zero and you solve the equation but you
wouldn't make the zero to find a maximum
or a minimum if you factorized what
would you do with that information to
get to a maximum or a minimum like
suppose I factorize and I found that the
factors are X minus 1 and X what does
that look like
I don't know 8 or something like that X
minus 1 X minus 8 so then what I do that
to find the maximum yeah I think that
was a really accurate and complicated
way to say let's take the average right
let's get halfway go halfway don't worry
it's my job to do this so you get past
okay oh we could say to create a job you
don't have one so look it um what do we
do what do we do we factorize and we use
the side relation to say well the
factorization gives me the roots now and
go half way okay however often you
cannot factorize right for a variety of
reasons so what are we doing such cases
okay we can get a quadratic formula now
if I want to find the middle the vertex
here the vertex there I can go to the
court ready for it but it's a bit
unnecessary really because there's
something simpler that gets me straight
to the thing I want one of the RIC here
you know you just stretchy heck I will
come to the completely square roots
that'll be another three because we
haven't mentioned that yet but to use
the formula
I don't need to go like all the way
through the whole square root of blah
blah blah blah blah yes all I need is
not the formula for the roots I join the
formula for the axis the axis of
symmetry I can find as just the first
part of the quadratic formula see there
it is right the rest of the formula plus
or minus the square root of b squared
minus 4ac all over 2a is to give you the
roots but if what you really what is
that guy you don't need the roots the
roots are actually just a stepping stone
to get to the vertex which gives you the
real Max or min so we've got
factorization we've got the formula for
the axis not for the roots and lastly as
we suggested we could complete the
square that's the other way that we can
solve a quadratic equation and it's also
a mechanism for finding the max or the
min let's have a look at some examples
of each of these okay consider okay let
me give you a function excuse me right
so when you have a look at this guy
we're looking factorization before you
guys are super good at factorization so
I'm not going to labor the point when
you have a look at this there's kind of
a clue by the way that don't don't
bother factorizing give me u and tell me
what the clue is it's a 7 right what
kind of a number 7 Prime jerks okay so
it doesn't want to factor up into nice
and deep and so therefore I'm not even
going to bother I'm going to choose one
of these when I'm actually selling the
problem now because I'm trying to
illustrate this to you let's just do
both ok so method number two method do
let's go ahead and find the axis of
symmetry okay
now please don't just watch into this
because X is equal to a number is it
could be anything it could be a point on
the curve it could be an intercept it
could be who knows what it is so when
you're saying this please tell me what
you're actually calculating
like so I'd be happy for you to skip the
- be on to a just go straight for the
numbers once you feel confident to do
that but our we're just starting off
with this so I'm going to write it down
anywhere what is - beyond - a in this
particular example 4 over 2 so I have an
x value now this is not by the way am I
looking for a max Tribune the only thing
that makes sense for this question is a
minimum because it's going to be concave
up so the question of what's the maximum
doesn't really have any meaning for this
particular equation so this tells me
where I'm going to find the minimum but
it doesn't tell me what the minimum is
how do I do that I'm going to well again
a really complicated way to get the
answer but it might be simple just to
substitute right I can take this I can
pop it into my original equation we're
just taking the hard way round for
everything today it's ugly into by top
line y equals 2 squared minus 4 lots of
2 plus 7 4 minus 8 plus 7 that's 3 3
right because this will become negative
4 plus 7 Todd are bigger okay so in
answer to the question what is the
minimum value though the mirror value is
3 right where does the minimum value
occur it's when x equals 2 so x equals 2
that's not the minimum value that's
where you get the middle value that's
what this guy's so maybe you want to
label that this is the minimum value
okay so that was method 2